[laser beam blasting]
[grunting]
[intense music]
Eric Johnson: In these scenes,
Black Widow is wielding
her weapons, and we can see that she needs
a lot of rotational power.
So the medicine ball rotational slam
is a perfect exercise to apply to this.
I'm Eric Johnson.
I'm a celebrity personal trainer to stars
like Scarlett Johansson,
Andrew Garfield, and Jonathan Groff.
Narrator: When Scarlett Johansson
first got the role of Black Widow in 2009,
she said that she had
never set foot in a gym.
So we visited Eric to figure out,
with the help of his wife, Melissa,
how he was able to take
Scarlett from never lifting
to deadlifting 245 pounds.
To help prepare Scarlett for the role,
Eric and Scarlett agreed
on a basic philosophy
from the very first day:
Focus on strength and
functional movement, not looks.
Eric: So, I like to approach the training
more as an athlete.
We wanna prepare the actor for anything
that's thrown at them,
so that they can do what they do best,
and that's act.
Narrator: While many movie stars choose
to focus on vanity muscles,
Eric and Scarlett knew that she was going
to have to do some of the stunt work
in these films for herself
and that having practical
strength would be important.
Eric: Confidence is gonna
be the biggest thing
that's gonna translate over
to her becoming a superhero.
Narrator: However, none
of this was a quick fix.
It took Scarlett about a year to achieve
her desired levels of
strength and fitness.
To achieve her fitness goals,
the duo split her prefilm
training into three phases,
each lasting three to 12 weeks.
Eric: We always kinda wanna be, like,
six weeks out from our peak.
But sometimes we have longer periods.
We might have 12 weeks;
we might have six months.
But I like to break up her training
into kind of different blocks.
Narrator: For this first phase,
Eric says it's about trying
to reset Scarlett's body
and building her mobility.
Eric: We're focusing on contractions
and building that mind-body connection
and developing her aerobic conditioning.
Narrator: With explosive swinging,
plyometric movements,
and muscle-burning isometric holds,
this phase sharpens the reflexes
and agility she needs for stunts.
A good example of where this
part of the training paid off
is this scene from "Captain
America: Civil War,"
where Scarlett really needed to be
explosive with her movements.
Eric: In this scene,
Black Widow is performing
one of her signature leg
twists around Hawkeye
and throwing a pretty high leg kick.
So she's gonna need the hip mobility
and the hip-flexor strength to nail that.
This is a move that she performs a lot,
so we do the 90-90 hip swivels
to make sure she has the
mobility to perform it well.
We're trying to optimize the body
to have mobility at the right places
and stability at the other places.
So, for this drill, we
really want external rotation
and internal rotation of the hips
by integrating the core
and a nice upright posture.
And we hope that this
translates over to the screen
in Black Widow's kicks and her punches.
Narrator: The second phase
of their training program
focuses on strength training.
Eric: In the second
phase, we're really trying
to set down the
foundational strength work.
We're trying to build muscle here.
We're trying to improve all her lifts.
That way we have more
strength to pull from
when we go into peak power.
So, this allows us to
go after those goals,
increasing pull-ups or
increasing our dead lift.
That way your body is
able to be more resilient.
Narrator: This strength phase has resulted
in Scarlett being able to
complete a 245-pound dead lift
and single-leg pistol squats.
A good example of where this
part of the training paid off
is this scene from "Captain
America: Civil War."
Eric: In this scene, Black Widow is really
showing off her power with her punches.
And you can really see
that her leg strength
is being demonstrated
and translated into those punches.
It's actually not with your arm at all,
it's all through your legs.
That's where this carries over.
If I wanna produce power, right,
it has to come from the
ground all the way up
to that fist running into the next person.
One of the goals we had in our training
was to do a pistol squat.
That was really hard for Scarlett,
and most people in general.
So we had to work up to it,
and we were able to do it
by the end of training.
What we did was Scarlett
would squat to a box,
and then we slowly lower
that box as she got stronger.
So this is a great way to
develop that leg strength
so that I can get that rotational power
and throw that punch.
Narrator: The third and final phase
is all about getting lean before shooting,
focusing on explosive
cardio, like sprinting
as well as kettlebell and
battle-ropes exercises
that increase heart rate
while building strength.
Eric: In phase three, we're trying to
increase her peak conditioning,
we're trying to cut back on rest periods,
we're incorporating drop
sets and intensifiers,
such as giant sets where we might do
three to four different exercises
for the same body part.
We're really trying to peak here,
from her conditioning,
from her athletic performance,
from just how she looks aesthetically.
Trying to become lean and really fit,
and really try to put
the finishing touches
on her character.
Narrator: Eric says that
Scarlett needs to be able
to do more than simply complete a move.
She has to move with ease and fluidity
while being as fresh and powerful
in the first take as in the 20th.
Take this scene from "Captain
America: The Winter Soldier."
Eric: In this scene, Scarlett's
giving a full effort,
full-out sprint,
and just keeping that calm
composure throughout it.
This is where our metabolic conditioning
really come into play.
So, one way we do that is
through battling ropes.
This is a great way to
kinda work on the cardiovascular system.
So here we'll work for
anywhere from 15 to 30
seconds, good, rest.
And now on the recovery,
we're really trying to
focus on your breathing,
trying and get your heart rate down
as quickly as possible.
And how this translates
over to the cameras,
like, we're trying to kind
of control her face as well.
So we don't want this kind of pain face.
So that way, when you have
to do the physical scenes,
you're able to do that
and look like a superhero.
Narrator: Physical training is paramount
when getting into shape,
but diet and nutrition are
also extremely important.
Eric: We never really stress, like,
specific macros down
to the gram of protein.
We keep it very natural.
We're trying to figure out, one,
from a recovery standpoint,
is she getting enough calories?
Instead, we made it more flexible.
We had chocolate cake
and dark chocolate and doughnuts,
because it's more than just
filming or looking great.
It's also about living and
enjoying the experience.
She starts to do this rope
climb, she's getting way up.
On the way up, she knees me in the face.
She gets way up, she comes
down, and she's so happy,
and then she looks over to
me and I'm gushing blood.
My nose is just pouring out.
So, she is lethal on the
screen as she is off. [laughs]